hi everyone it's jerry
on june 30th 2021 abhimanyu
mishra broke sergey karjakin's record
for
youngest chess grand master ever
caryakin earned the grandmaster title at
the age of 12 years seven months
zero days and that record stood for
19 years until now
mishra is now the youngest chess
grandmaster ever
at the age of 12 years four months
and 25 days so pick your favorite
superlative
it's a remarkable feat to say the least
and
i cannot help but wonder if this may
have been achieved much sooner
with the pandemic and all having its
effects
uh chess tournaments were of course one
of the many things
influenced because of the pandemic they
were put to a halt
until recently so
this kid from new jersey by the way is
running out of records to break i'll
share a few of his other
achievements throughout this video
something i'd like to share
first before we have a look at the game
that
got him to this prestigious grand master
title
this list here is the top 10
youngest chess grand masters ever
miesha at the top now a couple things i
found interesting
one is six of these 10
got on that list within the past five
years
and have a look at the number eight spot
who holds that one magnus carlson from
norway you know
the current world chess champion yeah
mishra beat out carlson to the grand
master title
by over a year the sky may just be the
limit
for this one okay as mentioned let's
have a look at
a game he played he's playing with the
black pieces here
his opponent on the wide end grandmaster
leon luke mendonka
this was a game played at a
tournament in hungary a round nine game
this is a 10 round tournament
that's significant that means mishra
earned that final prerequisite for the
grand master title
with a round to spare
those of you who may not be familiar
with how you achieve a grand master
title
the basic rundown is you need to achieve
three grand master norms
a grand master norm is achieved when you
perform at a 2600 or better
performance rating add a tournament you
have to do that on three different
occasions
and you also also have to achieve
uh a rating at some point
your rating has to hit 2500 or more
all of that has been met and we have a
new
youngest chess grandmaster ever okay on
board here what do we have
it's a grunfeld defense and if you're
going to play the grunfeld
you better be excited about having the c
pawn go to c5
we need to somehow coordinate with the
fiend kedah bishop we like to have the
bishop's eyes opened up
extend the scope try and make that d4
pawn
budge flinch so you could see three
additional squares
we also have a path for the queen to
have some dark square influence
all right white bytes on c5
bishop to e6 in general not a good idea
to put your minor pieces in front of
your center pawns to obstruct these guys
but
this move is certainly it has its points
it's
trying to resolve the tension in the
center
black would love if white captures on d5
here this would be a serious mistake
already for white to take on d5 why is
that
i'm just going to put one move on board
and then just say some words
this knight and bishop have been
improved in just one swing
not a good idea uh
you'll note for many moves neither side
releases the tension
um if you can control the knight on f6
playing as white here if you can control
that knight on f6
you are in a sense doing what you're
also controlling that bishop
okay don't let this knight move so
easily
all right what do we have knight f3
knight c6 all four knights
having an influence on the four center
squares bishop e2 queen a5
and now knight g5
uh these knights by the way a term that
i like to use to describe them
a term that i'll use here is uh
counterparts
this knight the knight on f3's
counterpart is
the knight on c6 and
i think this because they're both
competing for these same center squares
and similarly
uh the knight on the knight on c3 and f6
are counterparts they're both
controlling these two
light squares in the center uh why am i
drawing some attention to this well
i'll have a look at these next two moves
knight on g5
putting pressure on this bishop this
next move by black
caught my attention that's probably the
first move that caught my attention when
i skimmed through this game
black now plays knight to d8
super unusual but considered one of the
very best
moves uh these knights are once more
counterparts
a knight from g5 knight on d8 they're
both now
you know competing for these two squares
here black's
of course ready to recapture on e6
um and then be putting pressure on the
dark square bishop
white would like to avoid night
recapture with a punch against the
bishop so
in anticipation of that white takes a
step
back puts the bishop on g3
and only at this point does black go
ahead and release the tension
in the center capturing on c4 at this
stage
white takes the bishop has picked up the
bishop pair
queen a4 offering a queen exchange
it's declined queen takes c5
something i found interesting when
preparing for this video is
that black can actually exchange queens
this this one caught me
off guard i thought to myself
if you're exchanging queens like this
um aren't you going to
be down upon soon isn't isn't white
going to a
pick up this pawn and have this c5 pawn
uh secure and i don't really
see i wasn't really seeing a way for
black to generate
uh some activity you know where's the
justification for black for being down
upon
i like to just share where
where the compensation is
first it's knight to e4
take the dark square bishop and the
follow-up move
pop quiz what's the move here for black
feel free to pause the video okay here
we go
b5 that's a fork
white can take that pawn out by with on
poisson but
in the process what's happening lines
are opening up for the better developed
side the bishop is seeing
clearly white uh or
the knight has some pressure this is
still a threat b5
may hit yet again so there's problems
here black is
uh going to get the pawn back
basically is what this is coming down to
okay interesting variation black can go
ahead and take on a4 there
in the game it's queen takes c5 we have
a queen exchange
this next move was kind of weird for me
to see
i was king to e2 allowing knight takes
bishop
having these double isolated pawns they
don't really make a great impression
here
i must admit the the knee-jerk reaction
for me
is to back off and say i have your
knight under control
you're not going to damage my queenside
pawn so easily
uh how might black follow if if we have
bishop to c2
once more we can have this idea of the
the king knight hunting the dark square
bishop and the bishop being unmasked
right now black's ready to take the take
the knight and damage the
the queenside pawns um
so this this is a way forward for black
just putting on one move
if we have bishop to c2 you know we
could we could have the bishop backing
off and being in a position like this to
recapture but
okay in the game it's simply king to e2
with some reasoning maybe going like
this
saying yeah okay i have double isolated
pawns but you know what
we're in an ending my king is on a light
square
and a little bit closer towards the
center
my king will maybe have a little bit
better an influence in this ending
all right get the rooks on open files
they don't last long all rooks exchanged
end game on board which is even
no great advantage for either side the
kings need to contribute so
both of these moves are super sensible
upon contributing there's a path now for
the black king
some pressure on a7
of course that's spotted no problem
there
b5 white has doubled pawns can we
exchange one black says no no
not so fast let's hang on let's
let's keep you with double isolated
pawns still
knight c5 bishop c7
a4 and what do we have here this next
move
it's a big decision normally you
wouldn't want to do this
right the bishop is generally going to
be the better
minor piece the shiftier piece the long
range piece
pawn still on both wings of the board
both sides of the board still relevant
but there is this decision made to give
up the bishop for the night
why um well
you knock out a defender of d5 and
black's now able to improve the king
further so better king position for
black
and uh this pawn is maybe
not now that the king isn't on e6
anymore the e pawn is ready to roll
all right trying to provide some
some reason behind these moves here e5
knight b3 still main it's still
considered around an even position here
not winning for either side this is
considered better is to take with the
king and
put some immediate pressure on the e
pawn we have the capture with the pawn
maintaining the king on the fifth rank
king b4 knight d2 this is where it
starts to actually go
a bit astray for team black
and white in just a little bit
is actually winning but
as we'll soon see things turn
a mistake is made
okay h5 king takes a it's not the worst
pawn to
end up losing right these two pawns on
their own still can't create
a passer that one one pawn watches over
the two isolated pawns
but the white king could go hunting and
he's going to
eye up that b-pawn we have a little back
and forth here
this next point right here i think uh
may be instructional for for many of you
this
this this was for me uh uh like
this was a reminder at least this ending
here was a reminder to
um actually i don't want to share just
yet
let me throw a pop quiz your way white
to move what move would you play here
feel free to pause the video okay
this was a reminder for me to be patient
a position type like this the move
played was
king takes b7 and then king takes b5 was
played
you'll notice king takes b5 can only be
played
once white makes this decision
white is in control white gets to
control
when black takes the pawn on b5
white should be a bit more patient in
this position
and do something else what is that
something else
if you when i ran that pop quiz if you
thought to yourself
well maybe i'll put my pawn on h4 and
say aha
i'm clamping down on these two pawns
that gets a thumbs up
that's a good move and another one is
there may be others but another one i'll
just point out too another one is bishop
to g5
now why am i pointing out h4 and bishop
to g5
well again white should be patient here
there's no rush
and the bishop on g5 well i pointed out
with
what h4 is doing h4 is locking down on
these two what is bishop g5 doing it's
watching over
the pawn on e3 which is at some point
going to be attacked
and it would be nice if the bishop was
already in a position
was already optimized where it's
performing this defensive role
so that one day the bishop doesn't
immediately have to react to a threat on
e3
why can do both white can improve the
bishop white can improve his
king side in general improve his
kingside structure
a setup that would be really nice
would be to play h4 there really isn't a
whole lot black can be doing besides
just
waiting going back and forth in this
specific case if you try to
move forward in any way with this knight
let's say defending the b7 pawn your
toast
that hurts a pin and win of the knight
that hurts as well skewer town
okay you could play h4
let's just say we have a back and forth
with the king you could play bishop g5
you can go one step further
upon on g3 and even one step further
i like this construction right here is
what i'm getting at
where everything is defended
and only then pick off that b7 pawn
and then go hunting for all the king
side pawns
and let's not forget this is still an
extra that black has to tend to
okay i guess the short story here is
for white to be a bit more patient and
do some optimization
of the bishop in kingside pawns okay
king takes b7 on this move 44
straight away king takes b this is still
better
uh even winning for white in this
position
after knight to d2 we have king to e5
this is a
critical moment in the game the best
move for white is to say hey i have this
past pawn
let's go b4 would be the way to victory
here
i'll put on a couple moves knight c4
king e6
knight takes e we don't take here
because
what's gonna happen both sides end up
queening okay
but we push the pawn and
we're going to be the winning side here
i think the variation goes something
like this
where we get into a spot where
white's going to soon have two passers
that the knight cannot
the knight and king cannot deal with
white's gonna go on to win from this
position
all right b4 was not played
king e5 was played
yeah this is allowing a cool move for
sure
black to move the young mishra
what did he come up with here feel free
to pause the video
okay here we go the move played knight
f3
very sneaky uh we're landing a fork here
the knight on f3 is poison
should not be captured but it was
captured
and white's going to be toast
what's considered better is to s
not there king to f6 simply watch over
the bishop
this line may may come about where we
end up having
both sides queening here
something like this this is a just a
quick way to show how it could maybe be
stripped to
king versus king if we go into the king
and pawn ending right there
straight to kings it may go after king
to f6
a draw resulting but in this position we
have the knight being captured
black recapturing now runaway pawn
that's a passer
there's only one way to stop it
temporarily
bishop h4 who's this that's a defender
what do we try to do to defenders
deflect them so g5
scare the bishop off this diagonal
bishop takes pawn and the pawn bolts
so can't do that bishop f2 is played
what if you go to g3 you're going to
eventually scare the bishop
into a position where the king can
approach with an attack against the
bishop one way or the other
so white is not interested in inviting
h4
with tempo instead bishop f2
king e2 and
white bolts with the pawn and this is
going to lose
as we will soon see is there some other
try here
not really let's say if the bishop went
here
the king can play to f1 and
let's say the king goes here preparing
to meet king takes bishop with king
takes pawn
that isn't going to work either after
this move black would first play g4
and if you're approaching like this well
we could take the bishop and then be in
time to
push through are there any other fancy
variations to consider here not really
yeah the black pawns are simply too fast
so
i don't know maybe something like this
here yeah we have these two moves
the f-pawn too fast how did this game
finish
we didn't have the bishop moving at this
point but instead the b
pawn running but black will end up
queening first
and something special happens at the end
black will uh well something to note
here
a quick tip in these pawn race
situations oh who's gonna queen first
look at that in those race positions
when when
figuring out who's gonna queen first
look at the promotion squares and draw a
few lines
think to yourself you know draw draw a
file
along a file a rank in a diagonal and
make sure your king isn't on any of
those
lines there could be problems
there is a king on one of those lines
and it is a problem
notice this king by the way isn't just
going anywhere he might as well take a
pawn
right and that pawn is controlling f4
we're going to see the significance of
not having control over f4 in this case
this game goes no further white resigns
at this stage why
if you promote there's this trick
of a skewer and the queen will be lost
and the game is over it goes no further
white resigns in this position and that
is
this game right here is the one that
went ahead and put
the young mishra
over the top got him to that prestigious
grand master title really
again a remarkable remarkable feat
so feel free to share what your thoughts
are
in the comment section below if you have
any kind words to share
with the young mishra
feel free to go ahead and share them in
the comments below maybe he'll see them
at some point i love to see
achievements like this in chess and
we'll see who can maybe at some point go
ahead and break that record he has
certainly
made that task much more difficult
for those looking forward to earning
that title
at the youngest age ever or becoming the
youngest chess grandmaster ever
so we'll see uh how things shape up
again uh feel free to leave any comments
that's all for now take care bye